Good morning, everyone.
I wanted to hop on here and let you know that this weekend
we're doing a free Danish hook
and all the sourdough kids going out,
or all the sourdough kids that have been.
That are being ordered this weekend.
So I'm gonna show you what's in the kit.
So the kit is coming with two wicker proofy baskets
and also has a removable litter liner that you can take off and wash.
It's coming with a sourdough starters,
a freeze dried sourdough.
My freeze dried sourdough starters.
So very fun. Takes a few days to get it up and going bubbling.
This is a recipe book.
So step by step recipe book
with pictures on how to make your first sourdough loaf.
Also, fun place, like write notes and
all the things.
It's coming with a sourdough stir and a bench scraper.
And this week it's coming with a Danish hook whisk.
So all these things are coming in the kit this weekend.
Happy shopping day. Standing